[Music]
randomly youtube stuff like this because
uh i was interested in getting a tesla
at one point so i was like randomly
seeing all the uh the perks and you know
security cams on those teslas that are
like automatic sentry mode mode i think
is what it's good pretty cool yeah it
catches random stuff right away i don't
want the bitcoin now
i wanted
but i rather buy woo now you're [ __ ]
you know what you could see like a
scratch on your car little what the hell
and then you press it and i'll play on
the screen like what happened around no
way yeah wow it's sick it's ridiculous
it's like
really really practical yeah yeah
there's like cameras all around it i saw
videos of like a compilation on youtube
of
tesla's about to get rear-ended is that
what you're talking about just in
general anything tesla cam footage you
can youtube it and it's just it's about
to get rear-ended and the car moves like
two inches to not get hit
and be like oh wait while it's popping
on the freeway dude like well you're
driving and stuff but like for your
honest question why don't they just put
[ __ ] magnets in all car bumpers
i don't know i think no matter what
something's gonna go you might need a
really strong magnet they're not strong
enough dude what if the car is about to
hit the fly and then they smack someone
behind it some of those like bumper cars
like do you need to know that they just
they all have magnets so they all bounce
around
each other they're not gonna hit each
other crazy cars they're never gonna
happen and now the walls need magnets
dude you put it in don't smash against
the wall
oh i i see now because you have to spend
[ __ ] times on magnets yeah magnets are
expensive and then you give a [ __ ]
like me and i know that's going to
happen i'm going to go on the freeway as
fast i can't try to slam it to someone
everyone's just like wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
well you're gonna have a [ __ ] like
him he's gonna just drive backwards so
the magnets connect instead of push away
oh yeah
oh i guess i'm stuck to you oh geez i
don't know if that's how it works this
guy's a [ __ ] menace is usually for me
he turned around and stuff
anyways
credit cards just get erased as soon as
you
get in the car oh [ __ ] damn
[ __ ] credit card so tesla footage
reveals uh a man lied about getting hit
by a car oh oh [ __ ] i know it's so good
a man in slidell louisiana was arrested
after he allegedly lied to police about
getting hit by a car in a gas station
parking lot [ __ ] russians insurance
fraud dude
[Laughter]
in louisiana dude there's so many of
them well she has like no scratches at
all he's like oh at about 4pm officers
were dispatched to a gas station after a
man called 911 to report he was
allegedly hit by a car in a busy gas
station parking lot when officers
arrived they met with 47 year old arthur
bates jr
who claimed that tesla had backed into
him causing him to fall to the pavement
however he did not know that tesla has
sentry mode and has cameras should have
picked a camry dude come on
number one car in america
so uh later that friday the officers
were able to locate the owner of the
tesla spoke with the driver about the uh
the hit and run and then they reviewed
the footage and then ended up going to
arrest this guy damn
so yeah ultimately let's take a look at
this try to frame some [ __ ] yeah your
punishment should be it actually
happening yeah like they get a car that
[ __ ] hit your ass
that's true
isn't that is that double jeopardy
no no no what's the what's that's
getting arrested or prosecuted for the
same crime twice right
there's something about the idea within
that or like the the loophole or the
clause maybe i saw a movie on this
is that the one
double indemnity that one it's like if
you get like tried for it and like
convicted of like let's say i got
convicted of murdering you and but you
obviously just framed me and you're
alive somewhere and then like i can
technically murder you later true story
by the way
that's called i-409
okay wait for real
i like that
it's called hammurabi's law eye for an
eye cars are pink that's double jeopardy
so there's a dude right there he
eventually comes back over here
oh wait what i love these videos oh it's
incredible
here's the better part just keep
watching oh i'm so [ __ ] though he's
gonna fall over again he's gonna start
crying he's just gonna get up like
get your ass off of my [ __ ] car
that's hilarious y'all
so that that's the part
this is the run part
the quote unquote run dude that guy
looks so russian is crazy
wait wait wait how did he fall over like
he just ran into the car
so he's walking over here he gets closer
oh
it didn't even move it stopped it moved
a little bit it stopped and then he went
to go why did he have his idea just to
yeah he has no injury either there's no
injury now at this point are you allowed
to just [ __ ] his ass up like there's got
to be a point where you're allowed to
[ __ ] a guy up that's trying to punch me
right
after you [ __ ] a guy yeah you should
[ __ ] them i mean
you think the jewelry will like
sympathize with you and be like yeah
that's who deserved it
i don't think so especially if you turn
to the try with a huge cast or something
a cat a cast oh
right because once you watch that video
it's like okay after i watched that
video if i was a if i was in a jury and
then that guy got out of the car [ __ ]
his ass up i would have been like
justice is well served and you say
double jeopardy and it's all good dude
it's not really double jeopardy but if
you're in the jury and you're leaving
there after saying like nah [ __ ] you
you get to drive over this guy
as you're leaving he flips up over your
hood
that's the thing
it's called
nobody in this room knows what that
means throw your jacket over your
shoulder and say that's double jeffrey
do you want i would go to jury duty if i
get the run people over after
[Laughter]
everybody gets in the line 12 jurors and
run this guy over oh [ __ ] yeah joey did
you again best [ __ ] ever not really but
you know i was supposed to do jury duty
like this is like march of
just before covet
and then i was like hey can i put this
off for two weeks or whatever they're
like sure and then like they locked
everything down shut everything down
haven't heard [ __ ] about jury duty oh
yeah are they even doing court i have no
idea they shouldn't
virtual jury duty first you got to ask
yourself are they doing justice
uh i don't care
didn't want to go he just wants to talk
about the truth that's what you can
prove yeah that's true that's true damn
denzel
using the system using the system i
wanna i wanna that was the only thing by
the way that my dad told me not to be a
lawyer there's like you do anything you
want like just never be alone
and i was like why not he's like
sometimes you gotta fight for the bad
people and i was like
that is
the most profound thing you've ever said
to me
what do you mean sometimes you got to
fight for the bad people you have to
defend him well he's only thinking about
criminal law too because what if you're
like entertainment lawyer you just want
to make sure you get like blue m m's in
your trailer then what if you get a
[ __ ]
just just fighting for a writer contract
dude and he gets that wear shanky outfit
outside of the movie
serial killer and [ __ ] obviously he's
been watching too many movies
what if you just do pat and law and [ __ ]
imagine imagine being bart and being so
cute that you don't even know about like
all the [ __ ] up me too [ __ ] that
happened entertainment lawyers covering
for [ __ ] i was like harvey weinstein
that's easy and he's like dude blue m
m's or the me too movement more like the
me blue movement
oh wait it works in both ways
in there
stuff me blue but no yeah sometimes you
have to defend like an o.j or somebody
or michael jackson for example
michael jackson didn't even need it
[Laughter]
she didn't even need a lawyer dude if he
represented himself that would have been
the sickest [ __ ] ever oh yeah yeah
moonwalking everyone's like yeah
i like to present my case hit it
can we get a statement from the
defendant he's like i did it in a song
a song
no i'm bad
this one i call pretty young thing
whoa that'd be it i would still be
innocent yeah or is it the only thing
i'm guilty of loving all the children in
the world
blanket
blankets that's that's pretty guilty
yeah dude you have a son named blanket
you're guilty bro hmm
yeah that that's a tough one thank you
yeah i got a little bit what what would
you rather name your kid adolf or
blanket adolf
and look like blankets
because they're soft and yeah that's
that's what my thing would say rip off
their skin and you cover yourself
no like babies i just want to know why
why why a blanket yeah
your blankets are soft and warm and all
the [ __ ] they made me feel alive
[Laughter]
i like to imagine that's all he did
while he talked to him
the whole time or he had like a really
deep voice when he wasn't saying he's
like
i heard that he has a real voice that's
like like this like a like a grown man's
voice it's like gilbert gottfried
have you heard his real voice no he's a
real boy yeah cause you know how he's
like you know
everybody
but he doesn't speak like that he
doesn't feel like that you can hear his
actual voice he's like yeah i mean you
know it's a real [ __ ]
i ain't doing this character i thought
he always sounded like iago no from
[ __ ] aladdin it's a total character
there's no way he could live his
lifestyle it was like his stand-up like
bit his set his like uh who was he
playing his jewish mom something like
that i bet yeah or a parrot something
personal
you guys familiar pop smoke
rapper yeah the rapper who who recently
deceased maybe like a year ago or
something like that um his brother uh in
an article earlier radio interview
earlier this year talked about because
he's got a really distinct voice it's
like a really low like
really raspy love
but uh but the thing is his brother said
he never used to talk like that and then
one day he just came in and he started
talking like that and then it started
working for him so he just kept on
talking like puberty maybe
uh no i think he was already a grown-ass
man a lot of people have characters
though that uh that one female
billionaire holmes lady doesn't have a
deep voice
who's the holmes lady who she's like
this young female building there one
that a lot of uh she got like
she got like canceled or like whatever
for being a con artist or something her
sticker voice no but she has like this
character like this like
very distinct deep voice and it's super
weird she should be on a shark tank i
think yeah do you guys know flulaborg
no
the tuber
that's all
that's all i can say what's her name
he's no he's been in a bunch of [ __ ]
he's just in the suicide squad movie a
bunch of different [ __ ] oh but he's a
tuber he's a tube what's his name
flula borg flulabor and he's a german
who was he in the suicide squad movie i
don't know he gets killed quick i think
but but point being he has a fake voice
i didn't say that oh i didn't say
anything i just said his name and i'm
proud of him for being did you know that
that old school youtuber fred that's not
his real voice
no way
i'm trying to look up this flula borg
bit that's a crazy name b-o-r-g people
ask does flula borg really have an
accent fuliborg uses his atrocious
german accent to poke fun at the english
language of silliest expression okay he
owns it now thank god so he's not i've
known him for like a couple years so
yeah that was a secret back in the day
he didn't even tell oh [ __ ] he even told
his own
representation for like a while
they all thought he was a real german
guy so he has a fake german accent he's
like a totally thick proton like german
impression so he's not driven at all no
dude how exhausting must that be dude
he'll get headaches from doing it yeah
he says that he'll have to he would be
on set for things and he would get
headaches
because he's been doing it the whole
[ __ ] time he should try and she's
done a different accent it's much easier
to do like spanish or something exactly
like yelling german like thick german no
he's like doing like this like it's got
his tongue's moving in directions that
are unnatural for like his mouth
the whole day i gotta find this guy yeah
he's a good dude he's a he's funny dude
he's been on a bunch of stuff too um but
yeah no i remember having dinner with
him years ago with nikki
and totally just talks normal did he
trip you out when he when he started
talking like that no because i didn't
know his stuff you're like i'm trying to
learn german man i want to leak up with
you for dinner
exactly no no i didn't know him i didn't
know his tube stuff i just met him and
then i found out that he does this
german character and then i watched it
from there and then when i'd see him and
stuff i'd be like holy [ __ ] he's really
doing it the whole time
that's commitment isn't it
to be fair when i first met you and
started learning about all of our crypto
stuff i was like this is amazing and i
learned about you in a certain way and
then i randomly started youtubing some
of your old prank videos where you were
pretending to be like naked having sex
with people randomly outside pretty good
and i was like
i learned something about you you know i
mean
pretending i was [ __ ] them i was
straight up [ __ ] them way to say
mike's content dude